breastfeeding after the proper age which
i guess is what two and beyond
these days what do you think i never
understood that
you wanna know something chanel still
likes with my boob she's five years old
coco austin defending her choice to
breastfeed her and iced teas
five-year-old daughter
chanel it's a big bonding moment
for your mother and your child right and
a lot of people like oh you're not
getting the nutrition
after two years old why do it
and i'm like my child's easing eating
steak
and hamburgers she just likes a little
snack every now and then and more of the
bonding between the mother
why take that away from her she's so
much fun i mean i am like
my real life doll coco also says
breastfeeding
isn't abnormal because she claims in
europe they don't stop
until seven years old i think all women
do
something differently you know when it
comes to their child
but i don't want to deprive the boob
from her chanel even joined her mama on
camera revealing why
she likes it you know what what
makes me sweet she's a real fun
it's like the best best thing that
happened to us coco also says chanel is
allowed to sleep in her and iced teas
bed at night
if she wants we call our bat our bed the
family bed we have chanel
and all four dogs but the model says she
and her hubby make sure they have
certain days where they have a free bed
for their alone time
so the family bed arrangement doesn't
affect intimacy
too much how much does she have you
wrapped around her finger
i mean she has absolute control over me
i can't lie i mean she's so cute
and and and she's really smart last year
e.t caught up with ice-t
who talked about chanel's popularity on
instagram
can i ask you how it feels to actually
know that your daughter is almost as
popular as you are
on instagram the day she was born
we started her twitter page and her
instagram page because we knew we were
going to be those parents shooting 100
pictures out
and people like you putting up too many
baby pictures and like you know what
she got her own page and if you get
tired of baby pictures
[Music]
unfollow
you